bonjour sa halle au gras bonjour merci
beaucoup d'être avec nous en direct se
mettre un sur air sur rt france alors on
l'a vu le nombre de patients en
réanimation est au plus haut depuis
novembre 3850 malades et les hôpitaux
d'ile-de-france appel à des programmes
et près de la moitié des opérations
est-ce que selon vous le gouvernement a
raison de vouloir à tout prix ne pas
confiné on peut pas passer notre temps à
poser la question de ce qu'on devrait
faire dans la situation d'urgence dans
laquelle nous nous trouvons un bien
évidemment plus l'urgence est grande
plus le nombre de patients susceptibles
d'être hospitalisés en réanimation est
grand plus on comprend qu'il faut
prendre des mesures extrêmement fortes
mais on en revient du coup à des mesures
qui sont aussi des mesures qui ne suis
pas tenable sur le long terme et qui ou
quelque chose dans ces strahl c'est le
cas du confinement et nous ce que nous
récusons c'est d'avoir systématiquement
à se retrouver au pied du mur alors que
systématiquement nous proposons de
planifier la réponse à la crise
sanitaire que nous vivons lorsque nous
avons lu premier confinement il fallait
planifier le déconfinement effet les
planifier l'approvisionnement en masse
évidemment mais aussi en test il fallait
planifier les conditions d'isolement des
malades de traçage des malades pour
faire réduire la circulation de virus il
fallait anticiper la possibilité d'une
seconde wallon nous a rigolé hélas la
seconde vague est bel et bien arrivée et
depuis des mois on a le sentiment qu'on
est langue la gestion de pénurie dans la
gestion au jour le jour au lieu d'être
dans la planification des réponses donc
bien évidemment que l'afflux la
situation s'aggrave plus nous sommes
nous voyons à quel point le risque de
devoir recourir à un confinement globale
augmente mais disons que ce n'est pas
tenable ce n'est pas non plus tenable de
proposer des mesures comme le couvre-feu
à 18 heures dont on sent que la
population ne pourra pas les supporter
longtemps et dont on a sur lesquels on a
des gros tour sur l'efficacité réelle en
termes de circulation du virus à partir
du moment où les gens continuent à aller
au travail à s'entasser dans les
magasins aux mêmes horaires pour faire
la course et c'est donc c'est cette
situation là nous se prolonge depuis des
mois est très difficile à vivre pour les
français
qui globalement sont très obéissants
vous avez pu le remarquer qu'ils suivent
les consignes dès qu'il a le sentiment
que on anticipe jamais le coup d'après
la campagne de vaccination suscite la
colère des médecins on l'a vu les
médecins généralistes exaspéré notamment
par l' agence régionale de la santé
écouter on a balancé 50 dosière car la
rsa interdit qu'on les fasse au centre
de vaccination de clamart j'ai envie
d'aller dézinguer le ministère qui sait
ces gens incapables de s'adapter prendre
des décisions responsables réaction
assez fort car on a appris également que
les médecins généralistes ne pourrait
plus commandé deux doses de vaccin à
partir de cette semaine puisqu'elle
c'est l'accent serait privilégiée pour
les pharmaciens alors qu'en pensez vous
alors j'entends mois la très forte
colère des médecins
je vais aussi avoir un mot pour la
colère des familles des patients et
notamment des patients qui se retrouvent
avec des rendez vous aujourd'hui qui
sont annulés alors même qu'ils savent
qu'ils ont peut être une maladie grave
comme un cancer ou autres et qu'ils
comprennent que leurs soins et vos
gardes et ça c'est quelque chose de très
grave c'est arrivé et je comprends que
les soignants qui sont aux premières
loges de cette mission de garantir la
santé de la population soit exaspérés
par les consuls hibernant voilà on a eu
une opération communication ce week-end
où le gouvernement s'est targué d'avoir
fait un nombre record de vaccination et
le lendemain même on a des médecins qui
le disent mais nous on reçoit des
consignes nous disant d'annuler nous
rendez vous de vaccination de ne prendre
qu il nous explique qu'on ne pourra pas
recommander des doses
encore une fois c'est la question de la
pénurie nous sommes en gestion de
pénurie de doses visiblement il ya des
problèmes logistiques énormes on s'est
retrouvé à faire appel pour des sommes
monstrueuses à des cabinets de conseil
privé pour cette logistique alors ça
fait des mois que nous savons que la
vaccination demande des chaînes de
logistique et puis ça pose aussi la
question de notre une capacité à
produire nous mêmes aussi les doses de
vaccins dont nous avons besoin
ça pose aussi la question de la mise en
licence libre de ses l'accent que nous
demandons à la france est soumise et
nous pensons que la france devrait
porter une voix forte pour que justement
les vaccins de vienne
si dans l'ensemble du monde à l'ensemble
des personnes parce que c'est une
question d'intérêt général humains
silence on avait d'ailleurs appelé à se
tourner et peut-être vers la russie pour
avoir davantage de vaccins
mais est ce que je serai jean luc
mélenchon a dit c'est que nous ne
pouvions pas avoir un gouvernement qui
prenne des décisions de nature si vous
voulez idéologique qui nous emmène dans
ces situations pénibles et alors on a eu
la place et comptent pas et soeurs il
fallait absolument que ce soit le vaccin
facteurs dont on savait qu'ils étaient
conservés à moins 70 degrés et ça va
poser des questions de logistique énorme
qui posait un certain nombre de
questions aussi en termes d'arrivées
messager etc
et il y avait cet accord avec pas être
fighter et ils étaient indiscutables et
quand on parlait des vaccins qui était
en voie développement en russie à cuba
ou ailleurs ou en chine alors là c'était
hors de question d'en parler et encore
une fois on nous arrivons à avoir 2 se
rend compte qu'il ya actuellement des
vaccins qui serait tout à fait logique
d'étudier parce que quand on peut la
santé des habitants de son pays
on commence pas à faire ni des jeux de
finance et de compagnonnage financier
avec certains intérêts et certaines
grandes multinationales ou compagnies
américaines et on commence pas non plus
à faire des jeux politiciens et à
considérer qu'on pourrait se passer de
certains vaccins
parce qu'on n'est pas contents qu'ils
viennent de tel ou tel délit donc nous
nous opposons à cette logique là et nous
demandons une logique d'intérêt général
et nous demandons à ce que les français
puissent avoir le choix de leurs
vaccinations et le choix des vaccins
utilise payèrent soir gérald darmanin le
ministre de l'intérieur a annoncé une
protection pour les deux professeurs de
sciences po de grenoble qui ont été
accusé d'islamophobie on écoute le
ministre de l'intérieur et on en parle
après nous avons fait contacté
aujourd'hui les deux enseignants des
mesures de protection sont prises je ne
voudrais pas les détailler ici
ne serait ce que parce qu'elles doivent
être discrète votre commentaire sur
cette affaire
mais écoutez bien évidemment qu à partir
du moment où on a la certitude de
menaces qui pèsent sur leurs dégâts
somme que ce soit des enseignants aux
brosses ils ont droit à cette protection
et je trouve ça effectivement
bienvenue à partir du moment où senna
centre et moi ce qui m'a un peu inquiété
dans cette séquence c'est que j'ai eu
l'impression qu'il ya eu un emballement
qui a participé à faire de ces
enseignants des cibles et y compris un
emballement médiatique je vous le dis
parce que publier au sein d'une
université des étudiants qui puisse dire
leur malaise vis-à-vis de certains
propos prononcés par des enseignants qui
puisse y avoir un débat au sein
d'universités sur la façon dont on va
nommer une journée d'étude qui puisse y
avoir des échanges de mails un peu vides
aux universités ses seins ça arrive et
qu'il faut pas non plus que ça puisse
prendre des proportions pas possible
donc il ya eu effectivement un affichage
à un collage qui est tout à fait
contestable à partir de là ça a été
appelé ça a été nommé un appel au
lynchage et moi pour vous dire j'étais
hier sur un plateau télé où on m'a tout
de suite fait le lien avec samuel paty
et où j'ai fait remarquer que la le
professeur lui-même disait qu'il ne
souhaitait pas qu'on fasse c'est bien là
et qu'on passe comme si on avait déjà
une chaîne un emballement qui avait créé
une chaîne de violences et des menaces
réelles et des attaques réelle contre
contre ces personnes
donc j'appelle à la les émirs fait vous
en convenez srs qu'il ne faut pas
écarter néanmoins avec sa vie passée
version nommée cantine oui mais vous
voyez que il ya cet effet d'emballement
c'est là qu'à force de dire que de
critiquer qu'il y ait des critiques et
qu'il y ait des débats au sein de
l'université
ce serait mettre des cibles dans le dos
des gens alors évidemment il ne faut pas
mettre de cible dans le dos des gens et
il ne faut pas participer à ce climat
avait quand même le climat qu'on entend
depuis des semaines on a eu aussi
l'épisode avec un professeur qui a
acquis la parole a été abondamment donné
et qui a été présenté comme un
professeur
victime de menaces et qui a finalement
lui-même dit qu'il n'était pas du team
de menaces dans la ville de trappes et
qui maintenant se retrouve victime de
menaces ce qui est tout à fait
évidemment condamnable et est ce qui
fait qu il doit être protégé maintenant
les voyez cet excédent d'allemand moi
j'appelle à la raison il faut qu'on
puisse calmer le jeu est arrêté
dedans d'entretenir un climat où tout le
monde serait sous la menace permanente
voilà à l'occasion de la journée
internationale des droits des femmes
hier 150 personnalités ont appelé dans
une tribune à écarter des régionales les
candidats auteurs de violences sexistes
regarder jour après jour la parole des
victimes de violences sexuelles se
libère mais à quand une libération de
l'ecoute dans les partis politiques les
partis ne peuvent se murer éternellement
dans l'omerta c'est aux parties que
revient le choix d'investir ou non un
candidat est ainsi de couvrir ou non des
pratiques déjà connu alors on avait
plusieurs personnalités du monde
politique poursuivie pour ce genre
d'affaires est ce que vous pensez que
cette tribune est juste oui alors je
n'avais pas connaissance de cette
tribune où on m'a pas proposé de la
signer je crois qu'elle a circulé plutôt
en dehors de nos réseaux mais j'aurais
pu tout à fait là signé moi je fais je
m'occupais notamment de voeux du comité
qui a en charge au sein de la
transmission du suivi des questions de
violence sexuelle et sexiste et je
trouve ça tout à fait sans que
l'ensemble des partis politiques se
posent cette question parce que vous
savez une organisation quelle qu'elle
soit l'organisation politique
associative une entreprise n'est pas
imperméable et n'est pas à l'abri de ce
qu'ils traversent l'ensemble de la
société société elle est traversée par
des violences sexuelles et sexistes et
vous entendez comment la femme la parole
des femmes bardon se libère aujourd'hui
la parole des victimes de ces violences
sexistes et sexuelles se libère et il
est absolument décisif que l'on trouve
maintenant les dispositifs d'accueil et
des coupes de cette parole parce que
maintenant la parole est libérée est ce
qu'il faut ce qu'il puisse y avoir des
mesures alors évidemment il faut des
mesures beaucoup du côté de la justice
et de la police puisqu'on sait que quand
vous avez une plainte sur deux
violences conjugales qui n'est pas
traitée que vous avez des tam qui sont
qui meurt sous les coups père
fonctionnaire ex conjoint alors qu'elles
avaient déjà déposé des plaintes etc on
voit qu'il ya un énorme souci du côté de
la prise en charge par la police et par
la justice qui manque terriblement de
formation et surtout de moyens pour
traiter tout ça mais il ya aussi besoin
que dans les organisations
en interne on puisse aussi prendre des
mesures notamment parce qu'on sait qu'on
peut pas que on ne se substitue pas à la
justice mais on peut pas non plus
attendre indéfiniment qui est des
mesures de justice pour aussi goût
protéger nos militants pour très court
est ce que cette tribune appelle à ce
que les candidats qui sont soupçonnés ou
jugé pour ces faits là ne se présentent
pas aux régionales vous êtes d'accord
avec ça mais bien sûr je suis d'accord
alors évidemment toute cette démarche là
c'est toute la difficulté de s'écrire là
c'est qu'il faut qu'on mette en place
des procédures parce qu'on ne doit pas
pouvoir non plus on est content se
substitue pas à la justice et on doit
pouvoir rendre compte sur le fait qu'
évidemment on respecte la présomption
d'innocence et on ne participe pas à des
campagnes qui pouvaient des campagnes
diffamatoires sur des personnes en
revanche nous pouvons dire que lorsque
nous avons des dossiers des témoignages
et des faits d'hier en raison des
témoignages que nous avons du faisceau
que nous avons nous prenons des mesures
de précaution sert comme nous ne rendons
pas d'avis sur la nature judiciaire de
la culpabilité de quelqu'un mais nous
pouvons dire nous prenons des mesures de
précaution ça arrive ça arrive voilà qui
est des éloignements parce qu'on
considère que là nous avons un faisceau
qui laisse penser qu'il faut voir
protéger des militants si beaucoup sarah
halle aux grains malheureusement nous
n'avons plus le temps merci en tout cas
d'avoir répondu à nos questions en
direct ce matin sur rtl france